أنا
[موسيقى]
آنا
إذن 5 دقائق
2 دقيقة
هاها
حسن
لكى يفعل
llbean نعم نعم نعم
[موسيقى]
من
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ابتعد عند صعود سلالم الفودو
معلومات حول مستشعر المسافة المثبت
يمكن استعماله
كل مواطن بدوره
استخدام معلومات عالم الوجه العائم في الهواء
الحكم وتحريك نصف القطع في التوقيت المناسب
إنها شخصية ببعض الأشياء ، لكن بعد ذلك سأضربها
أحاول ألا أفعل
تان
أنا
آنا
بن
[موسيقى]
همم
كتاب
نعم نعم نعم
اليوم
[موسيقى]
دي جي
حرب
[موسيقى]
جوجو
أنا
جمل
[موسيقى]
إعلان
فقد ناجاتا وزنه فجأة عند 7 أمتار
لا يوجد حوالي 5 كيلومترات في البداية والنهاية
هناك كاميرا ويمكنك رؤية صورة الكاميرا
بينما هناك زاوية حادة من رحلة الذهاب والإياب
اعتقدت أن جرس الروبوت النحيف الأرز كان حلوًا جدًا
أنا في مكان وأستخدم طول السلم
على وشك أن يتجاوز
[موسيقى]